[Music]
bridges have brought people together for
thousands of years they've challenged us
as engineers created trade routes
between countries and have allowed us to
conquer some of Earth's most difficult
landscapes like mountains ravines rivers
and lakes but what about oceans could we
build bridges between continents where
would we build them and how would they
work this is what if and here's what
would happen if we built bridges between
continents the desire to get from one
place to another has been with us for a
long time in Mycenae Greece ancient
remnants of bridges have been found
dating back to 1600 BCE we've built
bridges in many different shapes and
sizes some of them are considered works
of art in northern India villagers have
even built living bridges using tree
roots yet for a while
earth didn't need bridges at all it was
one giant landmass called Pangaea but
over time Earth's tectonic plates began
to shift and Pangaea split into chunks
forming the continents we know today
with so many land masses separated from
each other bridges became a necessity
the desire to connect to each other has
pushed us forward technologically
demonstrating our incredible ingenuity
as engineers many ancient bridges are
still in use today such as the Mellish
River bridge in Izmir Turkey which is
nearly 2,900 years old but if we were
going to build bridges between
continents where would we build them
from New York to London from Sydney to
Singapore or what about a bridge between
Russia and Alaska over the Bering Strait
could we possibly build a bridge between
continents and if so what would it take
to build it
there are so many different types of
bridges we could build to connect to
continents but with so many important
shipping routes by sea we'd have to
allow boats to pass underneath we'd
probably want to build a railway as well
to maximize the usefulness of such long
bridges this could be beside a road or
below it the bridge would need a huge
number of supports to withstand the
weight of thousands of vehicles if we
were to say build a bridge between San
Francisco and Yokohama Japan some of the
supports would have to be built as deep
as 5,000 meters to sit on the ocean
floor the bridge itself would have to be
eight thousand two hundred and ninety
two kilometers long to put things in
perspective
California's Golden Gate Bridge between
San Francisco and Sausalito which is
just twelve hundred and eighty four
meters long took 1 million tons of
concrete just to build the Anchorage's
the massive blocks that grip the bridges
supporting cables it took 130 thousand
kilometers of galvanized steel for the
support cables to build a bridge between
Japan and California would be six
thousand four hundred and seventy eight
times longer and almost 33 times deeper
than the Golden Gate Bridge if we used
the same bridge design to get to Japan
we'd be looking at roughly four hundred
and eighty eight billion kilograms of
Steel just for the support cables okay
so we've done some of the math maybe a
bridge between the United States and
Japan isn't the best option but a bridge
between Russia and Alaska over the
Bering Strait might be technically
feasible some people have suggested
building an intercontinental railway for
100 billion dollars that would include a
ninety five kilometer under the Bering
Strait to connect Russia and Alaska even
if they could raise the money we'd have
to consider factors such as the
environmental impact and even politics
but if they changed the plan to building
over the Bering Strait work
might need to be stationed on oil rigs
along the way and construction could be
affected by dangerous weather the
construction could also affect the
ecosystem in the ocean and once the
bridge was built there wouldn't really
be enough traffic to make it worthwhile
but what if we built a longer bridge
over an ocean the longest bridge we've
ever built is China's danyoung kujan
grand bridge spanning 160 4.8 kilometers
that's a small distance compared to
going over an ocean we would need a
weather alert system in place to monitor
storms and protocols to protect
travelers from sudden changes in the
weather we might need to build a covered
bridge to protect vehicles from extreme
winds and in order to keep this bridge
operational there would likely be a
steep fee to use it and what would the
trip be like due to the huge distance
we've need gas stations rest stops
hotels garages hospitals even police
stations and unlike a typical road trip
you'd get pretty bored by the scenery
which would be kilometres upon
kilometers of concrete and water don't
expect any fun landmarks along the way
although you might see a whaler - we
even thought of building a chain of
bridges from Northern Territory
Australia through various islands to
Singapore
however with the majority of the
Australian population living in the
south
most Australians would likely prefer to
fly instead of the long drive to the
north
this series of bridges would also be
incredibly expensive to build and
require a huge amount of people
resources and time you can just imagine
the fees to drive across one of these
incredibly long bridges plus the cost of
gas and meals and hotels the long and
short of it is that we probably won't be
building bridges across our oceans
however it might be a possibility if we
lived on a tiny planet but that's a
story for another what-if